الى الصومال وختمت في قمه الصوماليه
جيبوتيه كينيه اثيوبيه للتبحث بشان الوضع
الامني وتعزيز التنسيقي في محاربه حركه
الشباب والتزمري مع العقاد القمه تبنت
حركه الشباب المسؤوليه عن اطلاق قذائف قرب
مطار العاصمه وينضم الينا من مقديشو مراسل
الجزيره عمر محمود الى ما اذا انتهت هذه
القمه التي خيمت على اجواءها تفجيرات في
العاصمه
هذه القمه التي تعتبر قمه امنيه بامتياز
حيث شارك كل من رئيس الكيني واليوتيوبرز
رئيس اثيوبي هو رئيس جيبوتي وبالاضافه الى
الرئيس الصومالي حسن الشيخ محمود الذي
استضاف هذه القمه وكانت الاهداف المرجوه
من هذه القمه هي ان تحصل على الصومال على
دعم من عسكريه وامنيه
للمعارك والحروب التي تقودها منذ اشهر في
ميادين مختلفه في وسط البلاد كانت هذه
القمه بمثابه
لهذه
المكاسب العسكريه التي تتحقق للحكومه
الصوماليه حيث
نجحت قواتها في السيطره على مدن وبردات
ومناطق استراتيجيه في وسط الصومال القمه
همم همم
اخرج منها عده بنود اساسيه بالنسبه لهذه
لهذه المهمه العسكريه التي تخوضها الصومال
حيث اتفق الجميع على ضروره ااه تشكيل ااه
اليه امنيه
يتشارك فيها كل هذه الدول المجاوره
للصومال من اجل اضعاف قدره همم حركه
الشباب التي يعتبرونها انها تهديد حقيقي
للامن للامن الاقليمي همم في المنطقه كما
ايضا همم شددوا على ضروره توحيد هذه
الجهود وهمم
تكفيه في المساهمه العسكريه التي تساعد
الصومال في حربها ضد حركه الشباب هو ايضا
تقويه قدرتها وتهديدها الامن الذي كان
يمتد منذ سنوات واكثر من همم حوالي 15 سنه
ايضا همم القمه رات ان همم مواصله الدعم
الحكومه
الصوماليه وايضا اثمروا
جهود الحكومه في بناء جيش قوي وجيش لديه
معدات عسكريه حديثه من اجل مواجهتها تهديد
وطلبوا المجتمع الدولي ان يشارك في هذه
الجهود التي تحاول تقويض تهديد حركه في في
عده مجالات كما ايضا
راوا اهميه انشاء
عمليات مشتركه بين الصومال وبين دول
الجوار من اجل امن الحدود بين هذه الدول
التي ترى ان حركه المجاهدين هي تهديد
حقيقي ليس فقط للصومال ولكن لكينيا
واثيوبيا وجيبوتي وايضا كان هناك ترحيب
لهذه الخطوات التي تتخذها الحكومه
الصوماليه في ضبط الامن والاستقرار
ومحاربه حركه الشباب في خاصه في مناطق
الوسطى شكرا جزيلا لك عمر محمود مراسم
الجزيره من